watch out for your limiting personal
beliefs when you find yourself saying
you know I hate doing this but I have
two or there's nobody else who can help
me or that's the way it's always been
done chances are it's a limiting
personal belief that you have and it's
not the truth it's just the truth that
you've created for yourself and
therefore becomes your truth and so I
was reflecting on my last episode
talking about the book where I said I
hate writing and and I have to I have to
just grind it out enjoy the end result
but I don't enjoy the process and the
past week now has been less about
writing and more about trying to get
people on my team involved in the
process to help make it easier for me
and while nobody on my team can speak
for me and can get the information you
know out of my head you know and I'm a
much better writer than am a speaker I
tend to think by writing it down there's
a lot of stuff in the book that they can
help me with there's a lot of research
there's a lot of quotes is a lot of
examples that people on my team can help
me with so for the past week I've been
spending my time updating my team
explaining the process I'm going through
and having them think about how they can
contribute to my project and right now
it's basically a team of four of us
there's myself obviously writing there's
one person who's helping convert all of
my content into a document that we can
all edit there's one person who is my
copywriter and she's looking over what
I'm writing and I'm probably gonna hand
chunks of stuff to her for example when
do an interview with somebody condensing
all the information and knowledge that
came from energy and put into the story
format making weird faces really doing a
live video huh you having fun on my
video that's Hayden and then one other
guy Jason who's uh who's helped out with
basically all the projects involved in
my company and he'll find ways to help
make the project right so um yeah that's
my quick spotter today that's the update
and I want to get to your questions I
promised I would answer your questions
and so I hope got a whole bunch of them
that came in from you guys so first up
jarhead 6 what program application are
you using the write the book jarhead I
I started off in a word and I have a
really unique format that I wanted to
try to keep too so it's easy for me to
design word now that I'm involved my
team in it it makes it much more
difficult because I don't want a word
document bouncing around the different
people and you can't keep track of who's
edited what especially people working on
at the same time so we're transitioning
everything to google docs and that's
what one of my guys on my team that's
what he's basically doing is taking
everything I've written in my word doc
and moving it to Google Docs and I'm
sure at some point when i get to the
publisher they'll use whatever software
they're using but i just have to give
them a manuscript and we're going to use
Google Docs or now crazy six to five six
find the solution as I hate writing I
can speak to anything but when it comes
to writing it seems I hit a roadblock
help maybe you shouldn't be a writer you
know that that's that's maybe the easy
answer if you're not if you're not
feeling writing don't write if you much
if you're much better speaker than speak
do you don't try to do something just
because somebody says is a good idea but
you know if you really have to write a
book you really want that as part of
your goals but you don't want to
actually write it then speak it out
right there are a lot of ghost writers
that can help you and you just do
interviews with them right and and you
know talk to your points they'll take it
and condensing and write it out for you
I'm I wish I could do that I wish I
could just speak from the top of my head
and have that turn into a book I have to
be a lot more I'm a lot more I take time
with my words I'm a lot more pensive so
not very good at that but yeah honestly
though if you're not if you're not
feeling it you know if you have a hard
time you have road block all the time
maybe writing isn't for you next up
Raunak thou so ha wow so ha wow i
butchered that name my apologies do you
have any framework of process that you
use while writing to curate and the
library on an idea as an aspiring writer
I would find it very useful if you could
share any tips on the same so this is
you know when you get into a big project
like a book you can easily get lost in
it and you can get caught up in the
weeds and so what I try to do what I'm
starting it and I'm no expert like just
as my first my first rodeo I write in
the book so uh
what i've done is i create iso with the
template there's three main sections to
the book and those breakdowns of
different chapters and I I started with
what ideas do i wanna what ideas do I
want to make come across in the book and
then I start working downward so I start
really high level start with the
chapters is to start with the section
then go to the chapters and then go to
the individual pages and there's a
format that I follow for each one and I
then I found that really helpful because
if I just start writing without a clear
direction then you'll find you get lost
you'll finally get lost and you lose
sight of the bigger picture and I find
that when I'm writing it helps to people
just get lost I like having a clearly
defined roles what I have to do today
when I'm riding I don't want to have to
think about the whole structure and the
bigger picture all the time I want to
get lost just on the one page that I'm
working on or the two pages that I'm
working on and so I find I have days
what I'm focusing big picture and lining
everything up and then days when I'm
just in it writing the content next up
stike 96 great video know what you mean
about hating the process but being proud
at the end of experience that loads of
times as to the book I really don't know
where to get started even if it's a good
idea because as you mentioned people are
moving over to other forms of media
looking forward to seeing you as you
progress this video's and I start to the
process right in your book yeah you know
I would say if you unless you really
examine your examine your your motives
right I covers a little bit last week
but why do you want to write a book is
it something that's just on your your
goals list your bucket list something
that you want to get done in your life
something you want to show your
grandkids that you wrote a book then
then do it right and you can sell
publish it and you've got it out there
if the book is only for marketing
purposes you want to you want to get
your name out there more then I would
look at it in a slightly different way
and that's that's the approach that I'm
taking you know the projects that i work
on i want to be able to reach millions
of people it doesn't have a big
potential impact i'm not interested and
that's why i wasn't interested in
self-publishing and if i wasn't going to
get a deal with the publisher with a
significant advance then
I wasn't gonna do it cuz I wanted
somebody committed who's going to help
me make this thing big and so that was
my motive for doing it uh I have a
popular YouTube channel I'm very active
on Twitter and Facebook and I have a
newsletter had a website i do all the
digital stuff as well i just felt that
there's still some relevance in the book
world but i wanted i didn't want my book
to stick him out and sit on the shelf
and die I would only do it if I got the
support of people who were committed to
making it happen so that could be the
same criteria for you you know if you
are writing the book only for a
footprint only for credibility only for
marketing your brand there may be better
ways to do it but if your goal is to
really reach people and you can get this
commitment of a series publisher then
that could be an avenue worth pursuing
next up Vanessa great tips right in the
book how do you start to write a book I
don't know how do you start to write a
book you start writing one page at a
time you know for me I guess it started
with i'll tell you the story and maybe
this helps my agent really wanted me to
have a book and at the start I thought I
don't really want a book you know just
like the last question I felt like there
might be better ways to do it and we
came up with a topic that I was ok
interested in but it wasn't really
fallen in love with it and so I didn't
you know I put a little bit of work into
it but it wasn't really consuming me and
I like to get lost in my projects
whatever i'm working on I like to get
lost in it and and be consumed by it
right you want to follow your flow
follow your passion and then throw the
process of writing that book and the
proposal uh I discovered the one word
concept and thought you know what this
is where I really want to focus and the
whole book is about finding your one
word how to apply to your business and
using tons of examples in case studies
and that got me excited and then I
started thinking well you know why do
people need this book what's so
different from this book and all the
other books out there instead of writing
my my outline and template and I think a
lot of people fall in love with the idea
of having a book you know having their
name on something having their their
name in a bookstore and that wasn't a
motivation for me
if that's your only motivation you're
probably not going to have a great book
like like anything else that you do you
want to do it because you love the idea
behind it right you for me I want to
have a big impact I want to reach a lot
of people I want more people to find
their passion finder one word and apply
to their companies and I feel like a
book with with the right publisher is a
great way to reach more people that's
why I'm doing it if you're doing it just
because you want to have a book out uh
you know that may be why you're having a
hard time writing it so tap into
something you're excited about tapping a
message that you want to share and I
think you have a lot more success in
putting words down on paper and I'll do
one more question empowering medicine
herbalist looking forward to your tips I
have an academic article i want to write
but I'm a perfectionist and this gets in
the way obviously Tom any tips on just
writing uh Tom this is a great question
and I kind of face that too i tend to be
a perfectionist and I see minor details
just just today I was asking Christina
we work on some new thumbnails for the
videos and I asked you to put two
thumbnails to little icons on the
thumbnail and one of them seemed a
little bit too far apart I said can we
move it to pixels over and she did and
and she said nobody's gonna notice that
difference and she's right she's
probably right but I notice and so it
makes me happier to see it as as I think
it should be done and I'm a run of a
quote from Henry Ford which is quality
is doing it right when nobody's watching
and so that applies to a lot of stuff
I'm doing including including writing
the book what I find helpful is not to
stress out and have to have the perfect
thing out the first time and and that
may seem like a juxtaposition an
opposite but what I find is yes I like
to like to be perfect I like it to be
exactly as I want it to be but I don't
expect perfection the first time a lot
of times the end result that you get is
a result of experimentation and I'll try
tons of stuff
and each time I try it it gets better
and better and better or or kill it and
it won't and so if you're you're turning
your your papers into a book I would
suggest don't worry so much about your
first draft you know just get it out of
your head put put words on paper and
then go back and edit it and fix it
because a lot of the magic happens in
indy editing and I would think about uh
videos and movies think about movies and
songs that you like you know a movie
isn't done in one take right are you are
you sad what happened you just making
faces you know movie isn't done in one
take you take pieces and then you string
them together and you edit them together
and so uh the same thing applies to your
book you know write something down and
know that it's it's just a brain dump
it's just getting out of your head and
if you tell yourself you know nobody's
going to see it until it's perfect
that's fine but don't make it perfect
the first time through I think that'll
that'll really help you just get
something down on paper all right that's
my update for the week I hope they'll
have more writing done next week and be
able to give you a further update on how
things are going maybe a little bit
lengthy compared to last week's video I
had a little bit of a distraction I had
a distraction this week thank you for
joining me on my journey and if you have
any questions about writing the book or
my process I'm happy to answer them in
next week's video leave a comment
underneath thank you so much for
watching continue to leave and we'll see
you soon bye bye bye bye bye magic
finger who has a magic finger you what
this is the magic finger yeah